بين اقرار ونفي مناورات نوويه المشتركه
على وشك البدر الولايات المتحده وحليفتها
كوريا الجنوبيه تناقشان اجراء مناورات
نوويه المشتركه للاسلحه النوويه الامريكيه
لمواجهه التهديدات المتناميه من كوريا
الشماليه هذا ما تاكده صول وتنفيذ وسنطن
الامنيان يجريان محادثات بشان تشاركي
معلومات
مشتركه في ما يتعلق بتشغيل الاسلحه
النوويه الامريكيه للرد على الاسلحه
النوويه لكوريا
اخره من قبل الرئيس الكوري الجنوبي الذي
اقر في مقابله صحفيه ان واشنطن تتلقى فكره
التدريبات المشتركه للاسلحه النوويه
بطريقه ايجابيه
للرئيس الامريكي رايه المعاكس لنظيره
الكوري الجنوبي حيث نفى في اجابه على سؤال
من صحفيين في البيت الابيض عما اذا كان
يناقش حاليا اجراء تدريبات النوويه مشتركه
مع كوريا الجنوبيه نفي اخر جاء من مسؤول
امريكي في واشنطن اكد ان بلاده لن تقوم
باجراء مناورات نوويه مشتركه مع كوريا
الجنوبيه لانها ليست قوه نوويه
تصريحات متضاربه تاتي بعد دعوه الرئيس
الكوري الشمالي الى تطوير صواريخ باليستيه
جديده عابره للقارات وزياده هائله في
ترسانه بلاده النوويه بما يشمل الانتاج
الضخم لاسلحه تكتيكيه وتطوير صواريخ جديده
لاستخدامها في ضربات مضاده ملوك الشيخ
العربي